こんにちははじめ社長ですあの
毎年多分春ぐらいかなぁ春ってなんかこう夫婦はしてるって買ったんでなってくるから
多分頭おかしい人が増えるんですよ
[音楽]
したことを入れねなんかツイッターでよく変な人がいると思うんですけども今回特に変
な人が
a 大量発生しております例えば僕のツイートがあるじゃないですか
多分まっすぐ実はいますよあもうすぐいましたはいこちら
トマトこのなんかねトマトっていうアカウントがめちゃくちゃ多いんですよ最近
esaki ちょっとあまりに多すぎなんでちょっとトマトってつぶやきよし
ぐらいですここらへんだがめっちゃ多いですねとマットイエローミニトマト白
土浦三トマト言うとなんとこの形も何かあるためにすぐトマトって僕にで広角くるん
ですよ白いとまたもトマトって言ってますし
これはトマト rainbow ですねきっとたぶんくらいのたないと思ってるんだと
思いますこいつとかやばいですねもうずっとトマトトマトって言ってます実に怪しい
follow よないもう用はと
part 店とトマトトマトすいませんが誤ってますねいやもうやばいマジでトマト
しか入ってねこれは凄いですね本当にとバトンなのかもしれない疑うくらいものすごい
トマトです黄色とかと思いますねあぼかと思いますねやまこの謎の猫と謎の犬に挟まれ
てるあたりがどうもそっからへんの界隈の方たちなのかなという気がしておりますと
いうわけで気
この動画はちょっと本当に意味不明です僕がに詰めても絶対もうリップの最初ホット
バンドとなったという待ってるんでうかも教区を覚えてるわけですよ中にどんな人が
やって何の目的でやってるとか今日は暴いていこうと思います
多分こいつが千万なこのとなとかたぶん先輩ですね@野菜のトマト
絶対こいつです早速 dm で私ていますまず軽くジャブですね
今日はもういろんなトマトにとりあえずちょっとアピールしてみましょう
聞いトマトにも行ってみます今日はトマトのイエローミニですねちょっと小さい品種な
んでしょう
こんばんはトマトブラック黒最もとで
ねこんばんは未成熟の緑のトマトですね出荷額なるまで待ってるみたいですこのトマト
は
不作でした不作のトマトもいるみたいですね入ってきて僕のツイッターがと下で埋まっ
てしまいました
今んとこ反応があるのは
[音楽]
イエローミニーが反応してません好きなトマト料理教えてくださいねそれともとあんま
好きじゃねえんだよね
これはもうぐっぐいやここはずっと強気でいきましょう貴様ね質問が来た枝や葉付
気づいたらキーロットバットとまた rainbow 紫魂とか
帰ってきています紫が取れず5金はちょっとるかかっておきましょう
何者なのだ
貴様は答えやっぱ new トマトが何か言ってません次はあ
幻聴か黄色とまた今日は元気がいいですね
あー紫てまた眠いらしいですねあ生トマトござい演奏ですね新手の嫌がらせかやっぱり
言うとモーターが僕のことを案じと思ってますねとりあえずもお前らが生んだのかを
知りたいですね杉山めっちゃくそとまたしゃべり悪魔とブラックとグリーンとまとろ
トマトのためはちょっとまたチームを越せる抜いております本家のトマトまだ何も喋っ
てないですね駄目だぞっ
つかめねーならちょっと皆さんに共通の質問なってみましょう
よし攻めるぞあなたは何者なんですかもうドイツストレートに聞いていますよなぁ陰謀
と鳩は怖いよーって言ってますねちょっと僕が聞いてきたれた恐怖心を覚えてしまった
んだ
メインもとモナコちょっとを立てってちょっと僕超えない人だよっていうのはちょっと
教えてあげましょう
[音楽]
酒とんだか前は素人マットはもう駄目ですねこれ様とマットになりって言いますよね
ねぇとか聞いてみよう
年齢ちょっと気になりますねまあ
new トマトはちょっと返事に迷ってますねこのか恥ずかしがり屋おおっと5年前
秋田
うん肇社長の大ファンの[ __ ]トマトだやっぱはじめ冊を僕の動画を見てるっていうな
ちょっと認めてるみたいですねだからリプ横グってくるのかな8イエローミニーは
トマト女に好きになってもらおうと活動しているトマト
あああ
あくまでトマトモデルいくパターンなんなのこいつらつかめねえなマジで
もうなんか用としている
で言うとまたはストーバーの先輩してくれます矢部 rainbow トマトはついに
目的を聞いてきましたね
コザ警戒心が寒くなってきていますあぶない胸射起動奴だよた縁と
うなぜかもうダメですね
ファンっ
んだ
キラーと思えない海 bad boys ある軟毛せてくれてますねちょっと最後に
質問で議論なトマトいるんですねほんとに素人マットがクロトマトとはいろいろいるん
ですけど皆さんの関係性ちょっと聞いてみましょうふざけ酒ず何がメリルあり決して
トーク番組とのトークがばかりとかあの僕にリップするとそのみんなが見ちゃうんかな
それでトマト釣りを増やそうとしてるらしいですね大
トマトなんかまで数週間前に出会っトマト
だめじゃ本当にわかんねー new た元さんは結構な速させるですね
アートマンと畑っていうグループが持ってきてるみたいですね
うーんイエローミニトマトからしたら家族みたいなものすですね
何って読め
[音楽]
me
ああああああ
えっ入って夕食でちょっと色んなと元に話しまくってみたんですけどもう全くつかめ
ませんでしたもう謎が深まるばかりでございます野菜にフォーカスを合わせて攻めて
くるタイプは初めてだったんでちょっとびっくりしました
まあけどなんかとまとさんみんな動画見て応援してくれてるみたいなのでまぁよかった
ですただ心通りなんだろほんとにね何にもおかんだか
たほどチュロスあの中身がん
[音楽]